so there's a rumor going around
according to dan rpk a book of boba fett
season two is in development now if this
is to be true i do hope that they change
some things around i don't want this to
come off as negative but to be honest i
was disappointed in the book of boba
fett i felt like there was a lot of
potential and the way his character was
portrayed in the show i reckon it could
have been better maybe i'm just missing
out on the character development for
boba fett but i wanted him to be more
ruthless kind of like how we saw in the
mandalorian episode when he was
introduced where he just goes mayhem and
just kills all the stormtroopers and
he's more calm and composed instead of
more diplomatic and being super
talkative even actor who plays boba fett
he went on to say when he was filming
the show that you know boba he's talking
too much in these scenes or less talking
but they insisted he should be talking
more anyway let me know your guys
thoughts in the comment section below do
you agree with me do you disagree and
you haven't already please do consider
subscribing thanks for watching guys